what's up fool podcast with Felipe
Esparza and Rodrigo Torres yeah man yeah
man he's by her wearing his black
t-shirt man when his cheekbones we're in
his hair so her hair lotion with a
thread float is not mine he's better
than three afloat is better than Tina
he's better than jockey club what are
you wearing on your hair what are you
getting a lot of beer those get it yeah
yeah all that stuff when this stuff
start to come out like five years ago
six years it's clear before like like
I've always had my long hair but I was
Sunday man every badge everybody who's
fat decided you know I'm not on the work
guy I would just grow a beard and cover
up all the fat of my face that's how you
cover of double chins and we're like Big
Pun always the rapper's they used to
have that little a little line and they
used to redefine with their new face
starts little chinstrap beard jawline
yes John stop wearing black t-shirt with
bright colors how's your weekend those
good creeping around that's about it huh
but what told you dog you're in New York
City I was in New York City bran would
say what happened man it got Fool's
April Fool's um Tracy Morgan's looking
how do you know awesome do one leg feels
heavier because of the settlement
looking good and he's I met him right
away he introduced me he messed up my
name first of all he said if he asked me
ten times how do I you say your name how
do you say hey I wanna mess up your name
how do you say your name I don't know
how you shot your mag no through the
future whatever so he said he brought me
our best ladies and gentlemen this guy
just won last Comic Standing
give it up for esta Ezra Ezra Ezra I
don't like that fool everybody just like
quiet brother whatever girl a microphone
that fool who limping away I said give
it up for Kevin Hart died man they lost
the item back full awesome dude after
that man you know I just do a ten
minutes
do 10 minutes in my sleep I could start
10 minutes of jokes
hell yeah so I didn't admit our Hitler I
give her next to 12 so I did 12 minutes
and I got off the stage and he goes go
back here come back here man how do you
say your name Felipe Esparza he was not
my you're the future you just said I'm
you're the future so he brought me up at
the future and I'm Lisa told me that he
felt really bad for messing up my name
kept talking about es drew Felipe Astra
how do you say how you saying uh-huh
so then um he said he don't know why
they were laughing afterwards right why
they laughing I may just say give it up
for Kevin Hart I'll see you man he got
tools
he got tools see he's a future a lot of
who would be mad huh oh yeah there's the
straight away from their actor how would
Willie Barcena at the head but somebody
notice a little gentlemen give it up for
Willie card dinner uh-huh hey bro what's
going on here bro forget crazy dog come
on all right if we get to a shot house
man tell you every time people start
turning off the podcast make it happen
Tony Perez listen to both podcasts in
his drive from San Diego to Rancho
Cucamonga to visit his side-chick no I'm
just kidding what scratch that out but
you know just talking laughs um lost
digits from Twitter who listens of their
every week that's those digits Marisol
Montes listen to both podcasts and I
don't know what happened but she got her
Instagram delete it
like somebody reported her but you know
me maybe nosey probably finding out what
happened I know like an Instagram fight
between her and somebody her some hater
I don't know the instagram fight about
but don't throw in our pictures at each
other how you how how you used to love
know how you used to look and you really
know like it's like a fight that you
could only have with somebody who really
knows you but I didn't get the fight I'd
only no one's going on
whatever man help you depart I hope you
get your Instagram back and things go
back to normal
too much information oh wow laughs Ron
Schara there it is
who says I Antonio Barrios from the
barrio this is to both podcast happy
birthday bro it's not every day or 17
George from what I never heard of this
or see man giving up for joy from all
see California he listens to it and I
choose and reviews it okay everybody
this is the important point I'm gonna
need everybody to right now we have the
next person next to you and make them
download the podcast right now hit
subscribe and subscribe or what if
you're not party with friends
and somebody goes to the bathroom
whether in a bathroom go to the iTunes
and subscribe to though
what's a food podcast it's really
helping us get get um raided last week
we were number 59 yeah out of our like
podcast gripple thousand we beat a lot
of people who think they're bad bro
maybe trying man people just show up and
you know yeah um we're just gonna talk
about you know and we had great coffee
to do oh yeah great coffee that's oh
yeah man I'm my nanny came over and well
I listened to the podcast about these
two ladies talk about take care of kids
and they both have nannies I mean if I
had a nanny you do anything I wouldn't
still be with my kids right now about
you really say you are the best way to
raise a family you know it's to but you
know some people are just too busy but
you need a nanny but I'm gonna have a
bodkin about perch we have a nanny you
should have run the shop but you're like
you're leaping on island guys they lose
their equal
you know it's that we're investing nada
nada I would want to be a Mexican ship
but I mean I was wrong skaters and
shouldn't be a two skateboarder oh yeah
dude I was in a book in a skater dude
watch TV series yeah Matt had no moves
but I just don't wear gloves from Sears
for everybody
pocket I was I just saw merge for break
dancers just Anna's
I think it old-school breakdancer going
towards Genie pants and scarves on your
legs legs warmers and go to Venice Beach
and get and then get jacked by vanished
shoreline Crips suicidal Tennessee so I
choose my brother's to skateboard and
hang out with Chaka from which live in a
little village there skaters their fake
scheme they were scared of Broadway I
started skating brought it was sad cuz
some people didn't have real skateboards
and this to make their own skateboard
man it's going guy hey Trey escaped hit
a skateboard but his will wear with the
wheel from the from the couch he's to
skateboard was couch wheels if we still
are Lee and then Tigger and then the
escape were returning to lazy boy so my
brother ever a good skater you know but
all you know all the dirty kids were the
best skaters do nah dude
cuz they had to like they knew they know
how to fix their skateboards and then
the thought when I thought I went to all
Sereno junior high school made a lot of
guys who were skating a lot of break
dancers and then I went back two rows
about I started hanging around with the
kids that didn't want to be cholos you
know there was a group of kids that used
to hang out together you know name it
was like maybe like a bunch of Latinos
one white guy who got transferred from
North Hollywood couple of Asian kids but
wish to a skateboard but we never bought
skateboard we took get our skateboards
for a Montebello we have to wait for
little rich kids to buy on them when it
when they're in the alley
practicing tricks but so broke here with
that crystal hood sorry give you that
vision board Papa rotor fool I had I was
at one time where I had like ten
skateboards there were no skateboard
shops in my neighborhood I was a
skateboard shop and if you wanted a
vision board bro Christian Hosoi or a
Steve Caballero let me see what I got
all the nails brother cuz I do this
about I should do it I do it no it's a
bit I said man when you mix a Latino
woman or
when you mix a wild girl was a Latino
man that kid is born it's gonna be the
best Gator in the whole wide world just
made cuz the best Gators are mixed kids
you got couple arrows so I would do that
bit
so that was Mary my the way I got in it
nice to watch a lot of skateboard out of
skateboard videos um remember that song
skate and destroyed a lot of our demos
and but I've never I could never
allium too fat you know I never got to
do no tricks I could never do anything
but down the fourth Street and 6th
Street bridge I should go down the hill
on a skateboard standing up fool that
was my claim to fame yup I was more like
a long long downhill rider than Trix is
you know man you gotta get them know you
know I just want to get hurt man oh well
that's the thing can't have no fear
doing them a lot of people my
neighborhood one great you know they
were not great you know and um I don't
give up after a while and I continue to
get skateboard for people Filipa skate
shop skate shop bro so actually our
guest this week we met him art briefly
yeah Humphries by the bay home free by
the bay you were checked in 2010 or
somewhere I know
yeah checking in the hotel right there
or maybe I don't know and you rolled up
I was using your white a man are you
Christian Hosoi and cuz I recognized
your face yeah do you know super cool
took a picture with this and the manager
kept in contact with them right no we
saw a picture with him real quick
and then we went to our room no that
night the night before we did a show
there for the Last Comic Standing
yeah do and if you guys don't know this
place it's like the one of the best
place to have a concert with kids cuz
they could be playing watching TV you
could go in the lobby or on your roof
and you watch the show show by the way
well I'll be performing there this
summer July 15 humphreys by the bay if
you can't get tickets get a boat our
town is that in San Diego
ok
now it was a trip yeah Oh another time
your name somebody named dropped you bro
and then and of course I should have I
should have said no this guy's [ __ ]
heed here hey get up with Christian
Hosoi and a drum circle you know there's
a guy Christian Hosoi was in Albuquerque
no it was close it was a Venice by
Marina del Rey by it by um by that I'm
cows and cafe there was a guy with a
bottle water full of vodka and he said
he was a drummer of bumps the butthole
surfers then for the psyched you out I'm
King coffee alright but and then I said
I took a picture with him it was my
first wedding day I had just got married
we spent our wedding night down the
street by the beach and we were walking
you know then this guy showed up because
yeah man
he missed your buttholes over yeah man I
know yeah skew the term a bunch of
surfers yeah man yeah yeah bro
so we started talking he wanted weed
everyday' of course then he goes yeah so
we did we going right now man i'ma go
hang on over there at um been down the
street with Steve Steve um that jane day
dropping Christian Hosoi we're gonna be
at the drum circle smoking a big do be
right here was this those two thousand
two years ago right I believe I do that
he's sober akin and his life's change
but I knew I said wait a minute I said
wait a minute Christian boys to hang
around with losers you know just to you
know a little taste of what what it
could happen and now it's down the
street trials and tribulations over here
but now so I really believe them I
thought maybe he's gonna attempt a
mystery how so I was a nurse Christian
was gonna be there anyways and I don't
know why I was a drum circle waiting
here the family what it's a circle but
then he's other names these other
skaters I got excited prom uncle go over
there
there's two people that I saw I guess
I'm gonna go ahead go Christian who saw
you liar he was da bra he laughs man so
la story short that's not King coffee
the drummer of butthole surfer he scans
a lot of people ah he's impersonator is
an imposter imposter the real can copy
hit you all right that you found the
real King coffee said That's not me bro
I joined I've died twice already so what
so were you the leader of your pack when
you skated back in the day with all
those boards no max I was in the back
last I couldn't keep up but I mean you
know were you kind of like running your
crew or were you just one of the bunch
cuz you seem you seem like a leader I
was one of the bunch but I was in charge
of merch merchandise I was like I knew
who wanted what who wanted what like
those are tiresome but it was people in
my neighborhood they bought they stole a
bunch of bombs or a drum set uh-huh a
whole drum set and there were these
crackheads they broke into the warehouse
and when the neighborhood was changing
people moving into the warehouse is like
laughs I don't know what to laugh worse
and they brought those drums anyone is
sick I bought the whole drum set for $60
the next day they stole it for 250 what
year was it
oh that was my 1991 Wow Pearl drums
other guy was trying to Robbie you're
like 30 years old now 47
wow you're my age I'm your age bro and I
still look up to you same age man ah
we're close I'm still older than be 49
this year but 38 on am DB I'm the BSA's
Philippe Esparza born June 11 1976 and
sinaloa me well I'm honored to be here
although to you guys called me in I mean
this is a treat I've uh through my wife
you know she was telling me about you
know your stand-up and all that and I
checked it out and I was cracking all up
thank you yeah cuz you know Venice back
in the day like you said the whole baggy
pants the breakdancing the hacky sack
all that stuff we'd be down there me Jay
Adams and we'd be skating around just
terrorizing the beach back then and yeah
shoreline Crips were down there running
the show you know regulating the beach
then the Venice you know all the the
kids that you know the Mexican kids that
didn't want to get in gangs were
skateboarding and surfing doing the
whole Mexican skateboarding and surfing
Association and we had a we had a blast
back there it was fun tired man yeah it
was great it was a good time to be a kid
cuz even if you even if you didn't live
in that area you showed up there from
the project's cuz I wasn't even the
project's no no like an hour and a half
away but I don't have 33 bus and I made
it there just check out the action
really cracking over there and also a
lot skateboarders showed up to my
elementary school I was a kid when I was
back in 1981 to do demos or what yeah
they did a demo there and I remember um
they showed up oh there were white kids
I don't know could have been you and
that one I was still amateur I turned
pro in 82 and so that was when I started
breaking out 81 82 we just started off
with who was the first team I started
with Z flex Jay Adams took me under his
wing and took me over to his spot and
just got me fully suited out with like Z
flex product then Alva put me on his
team Tony Alva and then stacy peralta
saw me and he's like christian you need
to ride for the Bones Brigade and that's
when I bought it for Bones Brigade but I
was still amateur and I was only 12
years old then I won the biggest amateur
contest in 1980 and then I said I want
to turn pro and Stacy was like now
you're not ready and so I quit and I
went to go ride for dog town and dog
town he's like Christian you don't want
to do that and I'm like no it's gonna be
awesome west humps tan you know all my
heroes show go Kubel were on dog town
and I went
they went out of business I was like
what's next and Tom Simms I don't know
if you remember saying yeah but Tom
Simms approached me and he's like
Christian I want to talk to you about
getting on Sims and I was like wow
Brad Bowman Doug Dumont all these guys
that I looked up to and I went there and
then he sold the license his name to
somebody else and so it ended up being
about two years before I actually turned
pro like if I were to stay on the Bones
Brigade but I ended up getting my first
model from Sims and that was that Rising
Sun bored
I remember that bored bright I had a
logo town gear too man oh yeah but
that's the right dog ton of ice on my I
was like a poser bro I had to add I
really couldn't skateboard I wanted to
be part of the scene but that's what all
the kids did though the locals were so
important you always remember that I had
the haircut oh yeah dude I think that
separated you when you started drawing
and you started doing the you know
having the board back then it wasn't
like it is now now everybody thinks
they're cool you know just because they
kind of can google it know about it but
back then it's like you really had to
know your cultures and that's what was
right about back then I know man back
then if you had a if you had a if you
had a video recorder you were God make
your own bootleg tape it's like I don't
even think we videos ever like back in
the day we'd go skateboard we go to
events and contests and demos and we
weren't thinking okay we should video
this like now kids walk down the street
they're videoing themselves we're back
then we didn't really think about it
then the magazines would come out be
like oh well let's shoot your photo we
play all right cool but really it wasn't
on our radar that we should document
this stuff I know man
back in the days man people people
wouldn't want to watch Christian Hosoi
folly on it and hitting his head they
would probably stop watching already now
you get a hundred million views just by
far lead oh yeah I could fall that's why
man like I always thought the
skateboarders they were like
God's because there was no there was
never no video out there of them messing
up everything we look perfect and I
would have saw them actually practice
our powder and I've been into it it just
do this looks it's unbelievable dude if
you really look at it you a skater and
Riverside to a grip dude fool just to
have their own ramps in the back and
[ __ ] all types of [ __ ] dude
rap a lot of vert back then kneel before
Street yeah upland skatepark right oh
yeah spot right there Stiller and Colton
all those parks back then those were the
heavy spots Inland Empire come on it was
it was a lot of battle between the
inland guys and then this you know the
Westside guys it was always kind of like
the bad landers against the dog towners
and there was kind of like a cool clash
back then because punk rock came in in
probably the late 70s and then that's
when skateboarding took on this harder
edge it was not your surf like style
anymore it became Punk rebellious oh
yeah had attitude it was all about you
know draining pools just localizing and
you know I think that that element of
the skateboard culture is what today
everybody's like kind of so attracted to
you know and and it's it's kind of like
a lifestyle moreso than a sport because
people you know now they see it as a
sport because you got the X Games you
got all these Street leagues and all
these things where they can go and now
they're gonna be in the Olympics coming
up you know pretty soon but back then it
was like we were outlaws you guys are
all just was pretty much just grimy
there was a whole thing that was just
going on nobody was really documenting
like you were saying if people had video
cameras you guys are just doing that
[ __ ] you mean and then I with the whole
punk scene to like you doing Peters all
those guys you know created that culture
as you say opposed to like you know
people look at how the [ __ ] do you get
into it or like dude that's so [ __ ]
cool now it's more clean-cut you know
polished up and all that [ __ ] yeah I
mean there's millions of dollars in it
now we're back then we're like oh we're
gonna get paid - this is sick you know I
mean we weren't really thinking I mean I
dreamt about it I envisioned that
skateboarding would be it like we would
make millions of dollars one day but
back then we were happy to make a
thousand bucks
first place and travel you know all over
the world doing you know what we love to
do right to get paid was just like a
bonus you know we were like this is I
mean I'm sure it's like that for you
yeah you're like I get to come up here
and talk smack to people I can't talk
about people in the culture this way to
me that's like a dream you know that's
like a dream come true
yeah and that was all small with you
know started like any one you started
getting the covers of like Thrasher
Magazine in a lot you guys were going
all the way to San Leandro doing those
small little ramp competitions and stuff
and if you look back when you guys were
doing K locals before was getting on TV
and all that [ __ ] that was underground
[ __ ] now you know you Gabri you guys
still represent the old school [ __ ] but
you guys still [ __ ] you know fledging
wrong with the [ __ ] torch you know
you're mad yeah Gonzales pool yeah there
was a pool called Gonzo's pool where it
was like iconic and today it just got
bulldozers no way what about that it was
right in like Mar Vista right next to
Venice abandoned was where Tony Alva J
all those guys had their you know
amazing photos and so for for for us
that was the elite you know and for even
today
kind of like the comedians that you look
at as an elite he's kind of like how we
look at certain things as being the
elite of the elite but I tell ya and I
somebody burning down the Comedy Store
this is a place where everybody hung out
and the guy had cancer like in a movie
or a different place no that was the dog
ball that was in the movie one or two
no I was too young I came in right after
that and so that was like on the tape
that's when the skate park started up
Marina del Rey skate park opened where
my father became the manager and that's
how I I really became you know it was my
life and I did it every single day and
hung out with Jay Adams Shogo those guys
took me under their wing and just raised
me basically as their younger brother
and that's how I really became you know
who I am today
you travel all over the world travel all
over the world I mean I don't know how
many times and I'm still not dead you
know I didn't die didn't kill nobody but
you know you would think you know living
that crazy life that I used to live back
in the 80s in the mid 90s it was it was
out of hand but um you know who back
then we were just trying to push the bar
I was trying to break records I was
trying to you know be on the cover of
magazines you know what it's like I mean
now it's about you know making yourself
known being an entertainer I was being
an entertainer through not only
skateboarding but through my lifestyle
and I think that there's something you
know to that and when people talk about
my story today you know or see my
documentary read my book it's like all
about the fashion it's all about the you
know partying it's all about girls it's
all about money traveling but back then
it was all about that and it really
created this this identity and image for
kids to like look up to I mean you look
at Superstars and kids want to while I'm
follow in those footsteps and so it's
kind of a big responsibility you know
what I mean when you're influencing
people and so now today I mean obviously
you could if you know my story I ended
up getting hooked on drugs and going to
prison and ending up you know throwing
it all away for a minute but through
that I've turned it all around and I'm
16 and a half years sober I've got a
family residence at 40 I'm gonna be 49
years old and I get to travel around
skateboarding all over again and it's
now my occupation all over again
so um get the drugs start in the
beginning whether Allah loves a lot of
drugs in skating or after parties or you
just don't know the wrong crowd cuz
usually for a comedian
it just happens like I was a sudden
you're doing stand-up comedy it's all
fun and games
then you're gonna rest it or order you
or some of your friends leave you and
you're hanging out with some new dudes
and it's two days later or you're oh now
like people just
like like calm they get um groupies mad
we wanna hear some drugs people handing
you packages yeah I mean it gets like
that people give it to you for free
other young but I started young I was
smoking weed at eight years old I was
doing how do you know if it's good at
eight oh you're right but how do you
know man hey man you know what I like I
watch you Popeye but yesterday I smoked
a joy it's just fun like no need to spit
oh my god man I smoked this joint man
I'm gonna go head back to breath feed my
father my father grew up going to art
school graduated with his master's
degree fine art Berkeley played music we
you know blues reggae I've even seen Bob
Marley twice I saw him when I was seven
and 11 awesome I knew every word to
every song so smoking weed was just
normal back then I didn't think you that
it was unusual I thought you were kind
of like a [ __ ] if he didn't smoke weed
at ten years old Wow I was hanging out
with my mentors and those kids were Jay
Adams and they were like 17 and I was
smoking weed with them I mean even with
my father my father was just like he was
kind of like a big brother he just
watched over me but it was allowed we
would just do whatever we wanted to do
and then I mean I got into doing acid
mushrooms at 11:12 doing cocaine at 14
completely addicted to it because all
these you know friends of mine all these
girls there hung out with all the coke
dealers and we'd end up getting it all
for free so we were just basically doing
a whole bunch of quaaludes
that's what method quaaludes were
happening man I don't know about
quaaludes to the Senate saw that more
the wolf of Wall Street but then there
were name a point where it started
interfering with my competition I stayed
up all night one night doing coke and I
went to a contest and I'm like I got
this
do we really guys write rails unreal I
end up getting like third place and I
was like this ain't working
for me and I quit and I said I'm not
gonna do drugs anymore I'm just gonna
smoke weed and drink beer and not doing
it anymore the Brahmas goes strictly to
wine yeah yeah drinking wine I don't
know what's happening but that remember
that time you said I'm gonna do why no
more chasing that buzz dog how sad it
was for me one time Christian man we're
just talking about in our podcast
I was so bummed out one day you know
you're normally when you're sad you
write your your grenading name or I'm in
China or I miss so-and-so oh I wrote
xaniix on that note with our heart you
were missed now that's how this out so
you said um um so what happened you went
now I'm gonna just try to do him just
bud and yeah yeah and that's where my I
like started really dominating
skateboarding like every like contest it
was my goal to strive to invent
maneuvers like rocket or Christ they're
all these you know maneuvers that I
invented and then you know in my
mid-twenties I ended up skateboarding
kind of died 90s when Street skating
came in and it kind of like threw us for
a loop because here we are number one
where the guys - now there's these guys
flipping their boards and they're the
popular kid and skateboarding contest or
going in a whole different direction
they're not arenas and big huge vert
walls where we're flying ten feet above
him it's like going over and riding on a
picnic bench and I was like but I got it
I got it I was like all right I'm gonna
start a company bla bla bla but then I
moved to Orange County and I got
introduced to crystal methamphetamine
and that's when I was like this stuff is
the bomb
I was like this is insane how come we
don't have this in LA you know and so I
quit everything else and all I did was
meth and I did it from 93 all the way to
2000 and I did it every single day from
95 till 2000 to the point where I was
just like staying up for days at a time
you know having bench warrants for
possession x-games was in 95 they're
like Christian you're coming I'm like
yeah and then I'd be in Hawaii take out
Tony Hawk yeah it was pitted for us to
go up against each other and ruler of
Manila and I was just strung out and you
know by the grace of God you know I
didn't OD and then I met my wife
Jennifer like in 99 like the end of
eight 98 99 and I mean short stories we
fell in love with each other I've pretty
much almost like first sight because we
didn't leave each other it's a little
volatile because we were all on drugs
and doing crystal meth and hanging out
doing well yeah we met doing drugs like
a total Bonnie and Clyde situation and
then I went to Hawaii
sorry we cut you all do you ever do that
couple move where you go hang around
with people you don't know just to get
free drugs you know what I'm sure we did
that together a lot team we were good -
yeah
respected you didn't study good for
sometimes man bonding class you don't
laugh ah no I just thought for that time
party what I remember a couple showed up
and I gave her a bottle of vodka and his
wife brought out Cubs from her purse
here we go the party didn't last you
know she had a friend almost OD at her
house and she's like I'm quitting drugs
I'm going to church and I was like sweet
I'll go search is good I'm good dopes
good skating is good you know me and her
good you know I just thought God was
about being good I didn't know that
there was a spiritual aspect
I went with her nothing happened did
drugs over there all the way back and
you know it says you know in the Bible
it says bad character corrupts good
morals and sure enough I got her back
into using and I went to Hawaii and
she's like like you want to go with me
and she's like yeah and so I brought her
and then I got arrested and you know I I
never grew up in church never read a
Bible name's Christian nicknamed Christ
in 85
ever magazine Thrasher says Christ on
there and I invented a maneuver called
the Christ air in the 80s mid 80s live
my life you know being called this and
no one ever talked to me about spiritual
things Jesus Prayer I didn't know
anybody who went to church I don't think
you knew anybody either right or did you
go to church I want a church bro but
that's doing whatever people outside you
know I raised Catholic but like I said
it previously enough on the other
podcast I will go to church I wouldn't
go inside I would just get the flyer and
wait outside and then when everybody
gets out and just loving you have the
flyer from the church or the mess and he
said it again menudo right but I don't
know her I was sit there as a kid like
we went to church or to church on Sunday
I was sit there like I don't know man
that message didn't hit me it didn't hit
me just on a beam of our violent person
then I'm gonna church on [ __ ]
talking about me mom tell him what I did
yesterday but I thought I feel too
guilty as in my church and for me it's
funny cuz I didn't grow up in church but
when I went to prison I ended up getting
70 months you know for a sentence you
were caught right in white cotton Hawaii
dealing the wood just carrying a whole
bunch on in their personal or to sell
well I was doing it for personal but I
had to carry a whole bunch to get
personal yeah yeah well you got caught
man because Hawaii trip was already up
turning into a meth epidemic huh yeah I
was an ice that's where I was I yeah and
I remember a man cuz I knew a girl that
lived over there
do Hawaii and she was sleeping man it's
hot out here with meth they just caught
the the model for this Hawaiian Tropic
she was bringing in meth in and out of
her competition mm-hmm
and then of course dog man the Bounty
Hunter he was busted for back in the day
yeah now he's busting people like get
back like you know what addicts hit that
rock bottom when did you hit it late
when you felt like this is it man it was
that first day when I got there I was on
the news and I get into the prison I'm
walking in and they're like what's up
Christian so I got you born when I was a
kid I was like what are you here for
he's like I'm here for murder I was like
I'm like sick you know tried to play it
off you know so you know how long you're
doing he's like 140 years double life
sentence and I was just like what am I
doing here right now and it hit me right
then and I made my first phone call to
Jennifer and I was like Jen I'm looking
at ten years and she's like you know I
love you we just gotta trust in God and
I was like I'm sitting on the phone and
they're all sitting next to you you know
on the phone you know you're get your
first phone call and why me and I'm like
trying not to cry you know already and
I'm like babe god I need a lawyer I need
an attorney yet I don't need God right
now you know I mean I thought you needed
God when you were dying when you're on
your deathbed that you'd have a priest
come in on a cockle sprinkle water on
you or something I didn't know I just
thought that it was like that and
hopefully you've done more good than bad
and maybe you're gonna heaven you know I
didn't know God so nice sometimes I like
these fools always show up asking for
[ __ ] when shits down my idea I was like
The Godfather you know I mean watching
you those types of movies I didn't have
anything to reflect or you know draw
from and she just said you just need to
go get a Bible in that day first day I
went and got a Bible and it was like
really on toilet paper pretty much I
mean the guy who gave me the the Bible
because there wasn't one on the books
he was in jail for like five years
already and he was doing another five
and he was just in transit and he's like
oh you want to use my Bible or one of
the veteran you know look like he's been
there for a while veteran all right and
I'm like you don't need it and he's like
no I don't need it it's cool and I got
in just like all marked up written in
underlines all these things and I was
like what no bro I was like what's these
columns and numbers I've never even
opened one up I've been in a million
hotels how many hotels have you been a
lot of okay how many of them me seen
that Bible in that drawer every single
one of them a big idiot road right yet
the last page roll of weed with writers
I put my weed underneath it so the the
maids wouldn't take it you know that was
my idea but I i sat there and opened it
up and it was like I opened it up and it
was like boom the scales fell off my
eyes like the first day because right
before I made a deal with God I was like
you ever come into that place you're
like oh god you don't I'll do this for
you I won't do this ever again get me
out of this situation
I made all those deals with them but I
meant it I was like I'll speak to kids
I'll tell kids not to do drugs again I
won't do drugs again volunteer matter
coach baseball league telling you and I
went to the the bail hearing in there
like danger of community threat to
society no bail and I was like damn what
happened to my deal you know but in my
heart I knew something changed because
it says that if you'll search for God
with your whole heart you'll find him
and I really believe that in that moment
I had a desire to know who God was
because I never had an idea and so I
spent the rest of that five years in
prison studying reading the word every
single day I didn't have a pastor I
didn't have a pre I didn't have anybody
telling me what the Bible meant so my
whole experience was just reading God's
Word and so that's how I have my
relationship with with God and that's
how I've come out you know obviously I
did like five years
and that I did it in count like two
years in San Bernadino County Jail
waiting for a bed a triple-decker bump I
had Bible and I was locked up for war is
twice and I saw the same Samoan kicking
me in right and I asked to some morning
guy who live over the same highway bro
no I'm not to get in your business could
ask for like I don't know write business
but you you were here in the last two
years I was here
you always hear what's going on oh yeah
man they got me 15 I'm doing 15 to 25
likes for life but I'm I'm waiting for
my bed you know waiting for for a Chino
to open up for a bed for me so you got
my wife we're talking about you could do
five years in county jail waiting huh
well I was a fed fed so I was at all
time yeah I was waiting for my
sentencing and I was like fighting my
case I was like nah I need to get like
look you know less time and I had all
these attorneys ripped me off my dad
sold his property in Hawaii and paid a
lawyer said that they were gonna help me
out really they couldn't do anything and
took the money and then we dealt with
that for like four or five lawyers
attorneys and then finally I just got
this guy who just said I'll do it it's
an easy case and he was a hotshot
attorney and boss all he was like the
cheapest and he got the most done
because he believed in what was
happening to me at the post
rehabilitation I was doing
scared-straight programs people were
bringing their sheriff's because they
used to skate back in the day they were
like Christian man we speak to our to my
church and he bring his whole church
into the chow youth to the mess hall and
I'd speak to the church about my
relationship with God and you know make
right choices and stuff like that mmm
I had my address in the magazine and I
had like hundreds of letters coming to
the jail and all the magazines and so I
had the judge sent all these character
reference letters and my wife put it
together my wife Jennifer put it
together and it was just like 200
letters on character reference and so
the judge took all that into
consideration and there's a downward
departure called post rehabilitate
and it's a huge point deduction and so
during that time there was no the the
actual defending attorneys could not you
submit these downward departures unless
the district attorney approved of it and
the district attorney didn't like me
because I didn't turn somebody in I
didn't you know cooperate with the
government so he was pissed he was like
no he's doing the whole 120 months and
he kept fighting that and my attorney
and him used to be district attorneys
together before and now he's a defense
attorney so they're battling it out in
the courtroom and I'm sitting here he's
yelling at the guy I'm like be cool on
the guy this guy's gonna hang me and
you're like just trying to hang him but
it was it was pretty you know amazing
how God in it through the judge being
official judge also Jennifer Willis 200
letters man God she got him on her own
by the way yeah I got an email for
somebody a Philippe it's gonna give me
life for delete I'm pretty sure you
probably know the world right to focus a
lot of people do get involved yeah and
that's the thing they came out to
support you too cuz other character
letter from people that knew you right
yeah people who knew me and Joe hundred
Jennifer went to like the industry and
really I mean I have she would like to
with a gator right no he was somewhere
else but anyway I think I crossed he
state you after in that prison I did a
show at Lompoc Lompoc yeah that's the
type of the gated yeah yeah I was in Las
Vegas I did mine at Nellis and it was
the one that what's-her-name I think
Barbara Walters did a special on it
because they used to have a golf course
a tennis court
Poole and when she did the active boards
because it was for fraudulent you know
it's just camp status fraud cases and
all these guys were just basically
having like a resort and when she did
the whole thing they took all that out
I put my put my form in for it and I got
it I was like it was on the Nellis Air
Force Base in Las Vegas because I did a
show in Lompoc and we were driving in we
took the whole tour of the Lompoc
federal penitentiary but there was a
side for you know for congressman's you
know for people who stole billions but
didn't kill nobody
yeah and they're like no gate they play
softball
maybe one guard was drinking iced tea
just watching them and then they could
really they could wander off like like a
regular person has to guard what are
those guys you know are they're just
they're just white-collar crimes they
just really one way if they want
yeah but they walk away it'll be in a
big prison yeah yeah thank you there no
I had no violent history crimes I didn't
you know I grew up pretty pretty clean
you know I mean I did a lot of raging
but I didn't get in any trouble I had no
violent you know criminal activity and
so I was able to classify for camp
status and so it was it was nice for
that reason but at the same time you
know it's still prison man still crazy
mad cuz it's a reality chain when you
walk into jail matter you're never doing
one day you know it's funny and I always
tell people you know I live my life
outside having everything on a silver
platter travel in the world money fame
all this but it felt like I always had
to prove or I had to like jump through
these hoops to make myself feel good try
to satisfy my inner person myself and
you know I was never really free like
content truly content satisfied and then
I got to prison and I asked Christ to
come into my heart and I was like man
all of a sudden I felt this freedom I
never felt before that I was who I was
to be in that I had a purpose that my
purpose was to influence people but in a
positive way to help people not make
mistakes were before I was like yeah
here's how you make mistakes you know
how you get to prison and I'm a good
example right but it was it was in that
place that I found true freedom and you
know everybody says how can you find it
when you're in prison you know and I
always tell everybody that I went from
instead of everyone saying I had freedom
to prison I always say I was in prison
my whole life not knowing who my true
identity was in Christ to getting into a
prison cell and being set free and so
for the first time in my life I was free
and how you know it's such a such an
ironic thing for there to be bars and
everybody to be going you're crazy I was
like man this is sick you know I'm going
to heaven you know I was like you don't
even know the things I went through that
I could have been in hell right now but
you know what now I'm going to heaven so
I'll walk to chow all happy I cruise
into you know the chow hall and
everybody's like all pissed off all
bummed to be there I was like what's up
you know I had peace peace and joy and
love and my girlfriend at the time we
were like I was like babe I love you
want to get married she's like you just
want me to stay with you because you're
in prison to be buyers and then you're
gonna be infertile you just you just
want me to be here and then when I get
out you're gonna leave me hon I'm like
me no I said that me no more I've
changed and she was like but then she's
like you know what I need to ask God
about this and she goes how do I ask God
and her uncle's the pastor he goes well
read the Bible she's like okay where do
I reach he goes proverbs and he goes
what where she i'll just read my age and
she was 22 and she goes well what number
should I pick it was the date 18 so she
goes 18 22 and it says he who finds a
wife finds what is good and has favor
from the Lord that's what that scripture
says and so she went got a marriage
license and ended up coming in and
saying I'm marrying you babe and that
it's a true story right there I thank
God because God hooked that up first day
rehab right back when I was hooked on
crack back in the 91 92 and I had the
same thing that happened to him but it
was but it took a while right when I
learn myself
weeping quietly by myself cleansing and
you can't really cry like that with I
guess you can't read cry so I would go
like somewhere in the woods and be like
I was all sad but then you know after a
wild man I felt happy again man and I
was in rehab I was just happy that I
wasn't in jail because everybody in
rehab were n numbers mm-hmm you were n
number you had what a Joe go to rehab
you didn't get that choice huh
no do you fight for that cuz you could
have got that maybe yeah I think they
called it I had a pipe with you yeah
they call it something but they in
federal prison a tainting like that you
do 85% of your time you don't do half
time and there's no conjugal visits you
know there's none of that
there's no furloughs there's none of
that but you know I think that's what it
took for me to be able to have that much
pressure on me to change my life cuz you
know I I could talk my way out of
anything I could pull any card I could
call any friend and you know and really
get myself out of any situation but
finally all those lines were cut and I
had to really evaluate myself and and
see who I was on the inside and through
you know that time in there I think it
really built a foundation for me to stay
sober when I got out to say you know
what I want to serve God more how do I
do that well you get involved in the
church I got involved in the church and
now I'm a pastor at the sanctuary church
and you know Costa Mesa and now I travel
around the world sharing my story at
churches all over the world and you know
and you know Jennifer we have two
children together and you know nine and
six and you know we've been through the
wringer even when we got out people
think oh it's awesome now everything's
great well Mary you know you're married
yeah you know I mean there
comes a point where you have to like you
know really deal with your personalities
and things you don't want to compromise
with and yeah I got baby mamas yeah yeah
yeah yeah classic right that's our son
here but it's rhythm is the 18 and then
I got one James and I have three
grandchildren is you a kid for us have a
kid named rhythm I think yep yeah I
think Chris kid for us son it's KD now
he's like nine yeah the little one he's
for sure yeah Wow we hang out me and Dad
yeah for sure Ed Gein coffee those beats
together but you know it's rad to have
you know Jennifer now she's even
starting your own career she's in real
estate and before it was like so tough
because she was always like Christian
Hosoi his wife taking care of the kids
and it got tough to the point where she
has you still with your like a soldier
yeah but she was having a tough time
because here comes you know her
dependencies that started creeping up
whether it was pills you know and
alcohol at times because there's L too
much it was too much and she went
through her struggles and then I got to
stick by her side and I think there was
this you know this almost like a change
of roles and I think that that's what
makes us even more stronger as a you
know married couple as a mother and
father as even pastors like she didn't
even really think you know she's like I
didn't sign up for this I wanted you to
change I wanted you to read your Bible
but you want to become a pastor now I'm
I'm not trying to get all crazy
and I'm like over here raising the dead
well has a water Aston Devils out of
people and she's like this ain't for me
well you know like you never watching
MacArthur Park and that's where I'm from
Echo Park you know I grew up there oh
yeah oh yeah and so for me it was just
like a no-brainer I come from the punk
rock you know skateboarding rebel so I
became a rebel for you know Christ and
it was just like normal for me you go
100 you know to me you don't do anything
half steppin and so you know for her it
was kind of difficult but now I mean
she's she's just amazing I mean she's
got like I said now she's like starting
to challenge me on making money she's
like I'm gonna I'm gonna buy the first
house I'm like whoa whoa whoa you know
you messing with my ego right now you
know I mean but you don't her and her
her was to was ourselves age again shall
we
I know man like when I come on a rehab I
have my parents this these two hate me
cuz they were Catholics but I was coming
from a Christian perspective now and I
was didn't I was like did announce you
know Bible whooping everybody at my
house fool went back to rehab yeah yeah
is there one alleged source yeah cuz
they don't wanna they wants to do and I
forgot that you can't change people to
just change yourself and they can accept
them so they come along they were hating
me yeah it's it's not being critical
judgmental yeah yeah yeah and that's how
the church you know a lot of the church
has been and I think that's been the
turnoff by people you know kind of look
at it now oh you're one of them and I'm
like no check me out for a while and
sure enough as time goes on you're a
good representative for that some people
are bad representative they grow you
know while you're a loser yeah yeah
you're a sinner yeah you're going to
hell
like be sweet everything my mom would
say you know you did a master baker go
to hell oh man the wonder man has on
fire but now she's you know my wife's
three years sobriety I've got 16 you
know I've got a company and I'm
traveling
oh yeah sixteen and a half years
the first photocopy you were locked up
so at least eleven you know what people
say that but it was easy oh you're gonna
have drugs in are easier no it's easy
you're Christian Hosoi they put over to
hook that up for the first one well
whoever had Supes oh man every two weeks
you'd get roast beef right and every
other day every day other than that was
Bologna for lunch and so I worked at
culinary and culinary yeah yeah
so cordon bleu we would sneak back with
a roast beef and we make a spread you
know in the trash bags and we throw in
the beef jerky and then you throw in
everything else the coffee the creamer
is the mustard everything you throw it
in there
mayonnaise if there was peanut butter
you throw peanut butter in there and it
was like it it became like it's all good
hi ty it's been like Thai food or Indian
I'm telling you I'll make it for you
sometime what was yours
we just came from what was the
restaurants name crossroads before here
and you know my wife said to you brother
Edwin checked it out and I tell you I'm
not vegan
but it was good it was good it was good
I had the chorizo oh yes scramble yeah
and the chicken and waffles and
yeah it was delicious and is that where
you go
we've been bender Russell Simmons goes
there we go to veggie grill on the other
place by the train tracks over here well
my buddy I don't know if you know trout
you know Travis Barker yes yeah he's
he's one of the night at little grocery
Oh blue glow schools he's one of the
owners at that crossroads crossroads and
so we gotta set up a dinner and go over
there and set it up go terrorize my
vegan date she was really blind but it
was delicious
you know I have to say I'm not every
time she says let's go to vegan I'm not
like looking forward to it but it was
one of the more finer vegan foods I've
had probably ever I know madam I might
want to tell people that my mouth my
wife makes ceviche is vegan they said
nah bro how you make it where you get
the fish from it's not finished bro it's
raw it's coconut coconut meats you chop
it all up and you put a bunch of lemons
and it's just returning gooey into it
and just take like ceviche man if you
forgot what's the beach it tastes like
lemon tea is good though yeah I remember
man can eat me much to make this
horrible not horrible it's too good but
now I think is horrible
she's just boiled chicken right and then
[ __ ] that'll be with rice don't be a
chicken soup just boil it bro like she
didn't clean it out like it'd be foam of
chicken for hours yeah so I remember I
got one of those meats and I put lemon
and Tapatio and I said man this is like
crab that was it went vegan
how'd it go vegan damn it tastes good
and I started make it tostadas that
tasted like ceviche but it was all
chicken man but they one day I thought
about us gross so stop eating that now
my spread how long has it been
um four
mm to five years now madam
I love 20 pounds since then so fat a lot
at first so you have a book yeah I got a
book it uh I wish I had it with me just
tell people don't ever buy it it's
called my life as a skateboarder junkie
inmate pastor and it's through Harper
one and you can get it on Amazon any
place like that but they we did a
phenomenal job you know you think about
these things you know you're gonna do a
book and you're like okay I hope it's
good but this one I'm is it inaudible
it's a I think it is you remarried it no
ah no like I want to do that and I want
to get it translated cuz all everybody
around the world wants to get it but
they're like that cost money and I'm
like well yes we need to race the module
could of friendly to Armenia yeah hey
bro
I also did a documentary called Rising
Sun with quit qd3 Quincy Jones's son
helped produce it with Cesario month
annual block is the director and then
Dennis Hopper narrated it well yeah
there was a phenomenal the whole project
came out like incredible for everything
of my life like all the way through to
the very end I was I was very pleased
with how that came out and you know for
something that you do anything you do
you want it to affect people's lives and
till this day I still have people
constantly emailing to DMing whatever
all those things are you know telling me
you know how they just watched it and
it's affected their life and so you know
I I really feel that that was a huge
success and so now what I really love to
do is like a feature film you know I'm
really trying to figure out how to do my
life rights for like a nice feature film
based on the whole dark side of my life
kind of like a who will play you Marlowe
right
no that's interesting stuff like that
you know some those are projects I'd be
you know really interested in in doing
you know besides comedy you know that's
my it's already working
movies alright not really I've I've done
like um cameo in that Dark Lords of
Dogtown but really haven't done anything
I never you know what all my friends
were actors I did this movie called
thrashing back in and that was a pretty
big deal but other cool boy was that
weren't on the hill yeah yeah yeah
there's a guy breakdancing yeah that's a
ghost man breakdance memory
good line in the movie right there yeah
and I look at him and I go wimps yeah
you was a big desert no we were I mean I
was in a real life back when you know we
were going to clubs like 8283
breakdancing was huge The Odyssey you
know so I mean three to one Santa Monica
loved punk gays like Adam did you go to
a lot of punk gigs too
oh I mean my dad Ballroom went to all
those places the Stardust you know who
all those places I mean I can't I was so
young and I was going to them I'd be
sitting there with I was sitting there
with long hair and I'd be like dang all
these crazy people and it was just like
super Punk like everybody had spikes and
razor blades and everybody's bleeding I
was like this stuff's just crazy I'm
like I want to go to the skate park
they jump by baldhead people just having
long hair I'll beat him up he's a long
hair little once they go at it like
heavy-metal Lunars antlers into my my
father through a huge like concert like
punk gig at Marina with fear Circle
Jerks the Joneses which was Steve
Olsen's band all these bands back then
and even the cover I think it's what was
it called I can't remember that cover
the band but it's at the Marina del Rey
skate park and I'm sitting there there's
fights blood everywhere Jay Adams has
now got a mohawk and he's doing
backflips everywhere and I'm just going
I've got like long hair Town & Country
shorts I'm 12 years old I'm like like
these people are nuts right but that was
the moment when it all changed when it
started getting red and gnarly and like
I cut my hair next thing you know I'm
listening to you know hip-hop you know
Herbie Hancock came out with all that
and then rated it rocket and I mean we
just got the linoleum the cardboard out
we're going to the parks now we're you
know we're thinking we're b-boys you
know what I mean hanging out at all the
parks back in the day then we go to the
club's in the circle the whole deal and
then I did that movie right after that I
was like you know Rafi yeah but I never
really got into acting because my my
buddies who did it they'd be like one
year they're fine cuz they just did a
movie next year they're depressed cuz
they can't got a movie I'm like whoa now
they're homeless cuz they had money they
had a nice place now they're like living
at their parents house they don't got my
I was like that's not a secure secure
job you know I was like you know
skateboarding is good I get paid all the
time you know and so I never really
thought okay this is like a career that
I'd wanna pursue because I had one but
now I look at it I'm like man it looks
kind of fun you know so you are that the
generation of skaters ass
- ha you got through you guys were like
um you get you came in and you were and
your style was different from the people
before you right
yeah things have evolved in the they
were beyond pools right you were jumping
yeah I mean we went from these narrow
boards to wide board oh yeah that wheels
started streamlining to where we got
them down to a science where they became
high performance and we're doing instead
of the highest air being four feet I'm
going like eight ten feet now and that's
in the mid-80s when it just really
skyrocketed on like the the tricks the
level of competition and then when all
the parks closed the halfpipe started
popping up and then you could put them
anywhere you didn't have to go to like
ask a part for a contest anymore you
could take it put it in the middle of a
parking lot and then you could have
these massive crowds then they go into
stadiums next thing you know we're doing
Stadium events and like Anaheim
Convention Center full of people and
we're just like its felt like rock stars
at that time you know the big F R ABS
better date huh
yeah enormous well was there money
involved like I don't even bother I was
just always sit like I can't skate man I
should have just be I should have made
ramps you know there was guys that were
making money making ramps because there
was a lot to do competitions and travel
but there was only a few people who
could do it because they locked it down
and they had it but we were making a lot
of money I was making nearly selling the
wood twenty to forty thousand dollars a
month Wow or a kid you know that's you
know 1890 death still from you
he was vice president of my corporation
so we shared everything in so everything
I made went through you know me and my
mom my mom was a subsea budget that was
there yeah I mean well I wouldn't say we
kept anything I think our whole you know
motto was we're gonna have fun and we're
gonna rage and we're gonna party we're
gonna spend it all you know and I ended
up or so was there
I need a buyer Harleys you know
Mustang convertibles in shortage you
know WC Fields estate right up there off
of Echo Park and sunset built a full on
32 foot wide ramp that was on the side
of the mountain where you can see from
Sunset Boulevard and just you know the
McLaren I mean you name it I was
spending taking all my friends to Hawaii
sponsoring people taking them all around
the world treating everybody every night
to dinner going to clubs eight days a
week you know and I mean it was pretty
you know pretty out there adventurous
mr. Lai say I don't miss that life you
but win a sense of like knowing why I'm
doing things but did I have a good time
oh I had a great time because I you know
built relationships I you know succeeded
in my career and accolades the
accomplishments the breaking records
Guinness Book of World Records I got
inducted into the skateboarding Hall of
Fame you know a few years ago and you
know one of the biggest accomplishments
that you could ever have in our sport
but I think the part of it that I'm
enjoying his being an ambassador for the
sport now today and kind of like still
being a part of it
vans is a huge contributor to the roots
and they sponsor like me Tony Alva you
know bands yeah guys like that and they
take us around the world and we
represent the the history of the sport
and so now I'm having a ball travel in
the world I mean fiftieth bands is on
their fiftieth anniversary right now and
we're able to go out and just tell the
world where it all started why people
are in advance and it's all because of
skateboarding and you know we started
this you know they're really giving us a
lot of you know of the credit for why
vans is this popular and as successful
as it is today you know and and I think
that's a huge huge you know I guess
affirmation for what we did for the
sport and so now I get to you know enjoy
without having the pressures of winning
the contest to get paid yes now I get to
go and just show up and just represent
skateboarding that's good yeah you look
you're an ambassador because you're
known all over the world you know yeah
dude like Christian Hosoi is up there
like Pepsi of skateboarding you know
even though you had your ups and downs
you're back
you know you're representing and when I
see like skateboarding all over the
world always thinking about you you know
Tony Hawk the people who are
representing like I saw a documentary of
um of a guy who went to South Africa no
Ethiopia and over there it's a bunch of
kids with skateboards and other
skateboards are given by people at
yourself
there's leaving a skate shop in Ethiopia
but there people are skating because you
know what you know people aren't
starving anymore but there's not a new
skater scene starting in Ethiopia and
it's because of you know these kids
don't even watch in the old tapes but
they're not watching the new tapes they
watching you two don't have YouTube they
got old vhss bro and the guy said no
memories other stuff they watch and it's
you know the old-school guys memory
worship knowing one day we should just
do a show and don't need a bunch of
scape words to all these kids in
Ethiopia yeah me and you should team up
and go out there and do that I'll build
a ramp bro well we could have somebody
else do that and I'll skate you you tell
Joe you do what you love to do and I
think you know what we can inspire a lot
of people around the world because I
think you know what what you do is you
give a lot of people hope that they can
make it out of wherever situation
they're in and I you know that's what I
want to do I want to give people hope
that they can you know come out of
wherever they're at don't matter how far
down that dark road they've gone that
they can make it back and turn it around
and start to do good again because a lot
of people just try and write people off
once they've done some you know crazy
stuff like I did and not saying you did
anything crazy but like you know for me
they're like yeah he's too far gone and
then when your life changes that I wait
you can be you can make it back from
that and then they're like I thought I'd
never make it back that's why I just
kept going down this road
so we saw you at home fries he said
that's good - Jose hosoi and I said
we're still locked up for us I'll tell
you were done well like I said this guy
was just locked up and that's it but
it's good to know you're doing well yeah
and I'm just grateful you know to be
able to spend time with my children now
you know endless in classic I mean
they're here with me hanging out you
seen him meet him but just to be able to
watch them grow up even hanging out with
my father we haven't hung out since like
the 90s and now he's living with us for
a few months and it's just been one of
those surreal times in my life and even
my wife she's now just become a real
estate agent I mean she's with a company
called case they're like the rising
company in the industry and so she's you
know got a whole new lease on life I
mean life is good right now and I'm here
with one of those kids that look up to
you - Paul Rodriguez yeah yeah you met
him oh yeah I know him really well it's
funny man how life is like my son knows
who you are
and he knows who powered Regas jr. is
and he wanted to meet them and then
growing up shocked out-powered Regan was
God like you know everybody I thought he
was my version of Richard Pryor for
Mexicans right right yeah so what is
your background by the way um Japanese
my dad's pure Japanese I'm Hawaiian
Chinese Scotch Irish French and Jewish
so my mom is her mom was Hawaiian
Chinese and they're all from Hawaii and
my grandfather bass was there the Beatle
right well I was going to say Mexican
because I look at it from Oaxaca but I'm
full mix and when I went to prison
though everybody thought I was like
they're like a all's like and I'm like
yeah I'm not you know and they're like
what are you I'm like I'm Jack they're
like you're lying you don't speak you
don't speak Mexican I'm like no I'm
Japanese Hawaiian they're like what
wasn't it then they point over to you
know whoever else to come once a day you
know
Godzilla in the water that's why but uh
yeah they were skating company yeah I
got a company called hosoi skateboards
and you sponsor people and this is the
30th anniversary don't have to graduate
a soy skates Wow
yeah I got one bro I've got it I've got
a cool team you know the famous color
right there yeah I mean here you go this
is the newest yeah my name is logo
obviously rise above and my father did
the graphics behind the first ones was
kind of like it's a tribute to all my
graphics get in Guizhou several John
Lucero did the the new updated you know
kind of like the wings and everything
dog town it's got the cross in it which
represents Who I am today and just I'm
having a ball man wanting to just grow
the brand be a competing brand with all
the rest of them like I was back in the
day and and you know I've got all kinds
of ideas I'm doing art my father's out
here doing art he's doing a lot of
graphic design for companies and we're
having a blast we're really having a
reality show well we're all there could
be the comedy I'm gonna give it for how
many right there bro you'll be the first
to hear about it but we're we don't have
you know we have a sizzle reel done this
for a reality show feels TV come on man
you're prophetic I'll breathe bring
money yeah it's a full production
company they did all you know 38 other
things TV we're trying to do it it's
kind I think we're gonna use the name
Christians Family Values as an effective
size Family Values like and it's about
all of them and so it's gonna be
hilarious okay yeah yeah see my wife
admits it she's crazy that's like that's
like mellow like it's gonna be it's
gonna be fun my kids are you know
they're they're quiet right now cuz they
they have to be right now I'm sure we
told them they have to be quiet but my
father's on it my other son rhythm 18
year old he's gonna be in it and we're
just gonna do family stuff on you know I
guess a TV level you know I mean I grew
up in front of the camera my whole life
and to do like a reality show I never
thought I'd do like just a home real I
thought it'd be some crazy reality show
like fear factor or something like that
but here I am doing like one that's on
family values and it's like it's almost
perfect because that's what I want to
watch if I'm watching TV I don't want to
watch something that's you know all
about this adventurous thing I want to
watch what do you do when they turn off
the cameras type of thing you know I
want to know what you guys talk about
what do you tell your kids how do you
hit the you know spank you can do you
spank your kids you know what is your
wife in you how do you handle an
argument I think those are the things
that MTV or those you know enter terror
I don't know the network's but you know
all of them Bravo
I mean you look at you know the famous
reality shows I mean really it's about
nothing you know if people just hanging
out - the reality right I mean so I'm
hoping it comes out funny and I'll get
your approval I'm sure
when I see you and you'll be like dude
boards not funny anymore there's no
conflict here
we need to strand it but I think that's
where we got my wife my wife is all
conflict and drama and so so I mean
really this they know that she is and so
they're hoping that she's gonna stir up
they they they're like she's gonna stir
it up for you homes they used to call
you homes right oh you're gonna stir it
up for you homes and you're gonna have
to figure out how to deal with it on
camera and I'm like dang this is gonna
be this is gonna be fun man you would
get like big-ass fools like my opponent
like my size I Love You Man I'm acting
like there that night man I'm sure
there's a lot of dudes get it all star
struck around you know oh yeah the one
lifts you up is [ __ ]
hug me hold my hair it is uh pretty
pretty cool to have people want your
autograph take pictures with you you
know I've been doing it since I was like
probably twelve thirteen years old and
it never gets old like on when somebody
ask you I think it's humbling you know
I've always felt like that because my
father my mother you know taught me how
to appreciate things and and and really
not take things for granted always
remember where he came from and to never
burn any bridges and for me it was all
about the fans it was all about the
people who supported you through you
know your career and I would you know I
basically a contest I'd give everything
away all the way down to you know
basically I'm not wearing anything but
my underwear and I'd be like driving
away in my town car you know going sweet
I'll see you next time you know I
remember just doing it it destroyed not
thinking you know how much of a you know
it meant for somebody else but what it
meant for me and so today I like think
about and I go wow this is dope you know
I mean whatever the kid I thought
none of these dudes did drugs I thought
they were all a girl is that oh I
thought that nobody kept these guys on
drugs so I never did drugs because I
thought these guys didn't do drugs and
then I'm thinking play the audio drug
I'm glad they know that back then then
they don't know TMZ back then yeah I
really thought everybody was so but
everybody was focused then you come in
and I said I guess yeah man I don't know
what I'm talking about
sure the first time I smoked smelled
weed was around skateboarders then you
wonder why I ended up where I ended up
right you know what like speed it shake
see oh yeah there is a lower kind of
like in that culture surfing skating
it's like quit school drop out and live
this like almost like gypsy life where
you don't work and you know back then
there really wasn't a career as so much
as it is today where I created a career
for myself
when I was like 15 years old I was like
okay I'm gonna make money this is gonna
be what I do I'm gonna this is gonna be
my occupation and if this is you know if
I could do this for a living I'll never
work a day of my life because I just
love doing it you know that's what was
my whole intentions but you know peer
pressure comes on and now you're like
everybody's putting you on a pedestal
and you're like wait I got a I got a
fifth apart you know I mean rock stars
got to fit the part I need my
convertible four coats I don't know if
it's like that in the comedian world you
got a lot of peer pressure there
comedian wants that little blue chick
approved on Twitter Wow
wake up begging I can't believe I got a
hundred thousand followers and I'm not
approved to think of the things that now
you're looking forward to or back then
there was none of that
hi there was this particular baking room
hell yeah don't to get somewhere you
need a Thomas guide you know I mean
there was no MapQuest hell no that's to
be my old joke I should say man if you
live you can't pick up with women
through this who live too far if I have
to look look you up on Thomas guide is
over what you're on for page 45 6b but
it's out of your jurisdiction or Thomas
guide to find out where you live I got a
brother Riverside Riverside County
Thomas guy they're all shipping will hit
the Orange County get that you're gonna
get the correct spelling by the way mr.
Omar with one L so what's up fool this
week I'll be the Tempe improv with well
Gino Torres and Keith Manning get off
the field April 7 through 10 April 16
I've been on passo at the abran Chavez
theater hopefully it'll be more than 50
people you know your story all that goes
April 21st to 23rd I'll be a Reno Nevada
Reno Tahoe comedy club with Rodrigo
Tourism and April 28th through May 1st
Houston Texas at the Houston improv with
Rodrigo Torres I don't know and gene
pompa licious Tompa so what's up fool
any question or guess broke Christian
Hosoi
and how crazy was it was like um back in
the day like in like when Thrasher first
started coming out did you ever like
face any racial [ __ ] people talking you
know there was really none because
skateboarding was such a almost like a
minority you know sport at the time so
we were kind of like the rebels and and
when you had like blacks whites Mexicans
Asians all hang out together it was like
whoa this is this is like they're
breaking down the barriers of racial
tension you know that's why the
gangsters that would get involved in
Venice or something like that they're
like yeah I don't want to be in gangs so
they come over and then they'd be like
oh man what's happened to you you turned
into a white boy you got me and but he's
over here was a bunch of like you know
Asian
y-you know and and I think that we
really broke down that barrier of being
cool to be a minority man you know
across the board whether it be music you
know cuz it's hard to you know almost
like influence people on a cultural
level like subculture skateboarding
became this thing that affected fashion
affected music affected like lifestyle
like we were we weren't having it we're
like no that's lame this is those are
cooks and we're cool you know what I
mean we were very opinionated and I
think that that's where skateboarding
stepped out and took that risk you know
rock stars they were like high as a kite
so they were like floating around with
like scarves and stuff you know and
wearing some crazy stuff and and but
there was some that were about the craft
and so that propelled them to be you
know obviously the best at what they do
but they weren't sitting here trying to
tell the world how you know what school
or skateboarders you know were at the
time and so you know I don't think I I
thought I was one trying to tell people
what was up you know in it growing up in
LA especially I think such a melting pot
of different races that we thought it
was lame to have any racial tension you
know at that time we were like no we're
sticking up for each other and that
broke down a lot of walls on you know
the racial tension in the streets where
gangs obviously I went to prison I know
how it is you know that that segregation
was hard
politics are real and so when I think
about you know my time in prison I'm
thankful because I learned what that was
really like and I I got to understand
and how they had to get along and deal
with each other and have to keep that
line hard there was no going over it
because there's such a history of like
the war against you know racial war but
out on the streets we were like no we're
free we can do whatever we want you know
and so there was really no pressure on
me being a mind
already at all I don't think ya man
having a skateboard man you know a cholo
back in the days that was your safety
name now bro I don't gangbang look at my
board do a trick I can't do any tricks
still boards were so full podcast with
our guest Christian Hosoi up inhale all
the way from Echo Park and people Union
area the legendary legend when is this
coming on this Friday yeah and if you
want to promote yeah I'm gonna be
speaking at a up in Diamond Bar on
Sunday at a raw Reese's Church it's a
Calvary but it's called shine and I'll
be there Sunday night it's with the
whosoever's I don't know if you know
sonny from p OD eat the ban p OD it he's
the one who started this whole
whosoever's movement and it's kind of
like reaching people who normally
wouldn't go to church that are into you
know whether it be motorcycles tattoos
you know punk rock music and just you
know hardcore lifestyle growing up you
know gangbang and whatever it is but it
reaches that rule so I'll be speaking
Sunday night I'll be posting it on my
social medias hell yeah you know all my
social media what's your Instagram it's
Christian and soy olive Witter Twitter
Christian Hosoi the blue chase I got my
Blue Chair but you know to get mentions
I guess right you have to have a blue
check yeah and so I thought that that
was kind of a trip I still haven't used
it yet
I just got it so I'm new at how to
really use actually I just got on
snapchat for the first time because my
wife was like this is fun I was like
what's so fun about that I thought it
was like this thing that kids did
receive pictures to each other and then
they erase real quick right I just
thought that that's what it was for but
that's what it was for now it's changed
and everybody's like you know I'm gonna
keep up but my periscope Instagram
Twitter face
I'm even on the other one
rest interest send me some vegan recipes
no no full podcast thank you very much
Jennifer ho Sawyer for hooking it up
take Christian Hosoi for being a good
guest the best guest man people that I
appreciate thank you the board sign it
please
it's all baby a man thank you very much
seriously keep shining with what you're
doing man I appreciate that thank you
for having me on the show
sign it wait I need to come check y'all
live now we're gonna be at the oh yeah
April 20 we're having the 100
anniversary comedy strike me a jig or
what we'll be hosting the show 100
episode 100 episode show oh yeah I saw
the Pasadena all right local all right
also Brea improving garages you'll see
the full one-hour show yeah and then I
saw we'll just promote we're just both
doing stand-up comedy who do a word oh
yeah right set you up for jobs you set
me up for jokes that's it I love doing
radio yeah I'd love to come check that
out date night right yeah date night
date night I saw they'll be forth we
have a lot of comedians I've been in the
show you know
jean-georges Coco dealer maybe that's
why I might be that you never know gotta
go to Buffalo
Groucho be though oh you need to bring
skates gene pompa licious okay we'll be
on to more people scratch oh gee Papa
also people April 15 five days before
the show well you go to the P over there
where's our Chapel now if pops it up
Gracie headlining show
need any lessons
thanks to a Phase two yeah there's no
bro
hell yeah what's a little May ready go
back home alright well so full podcast
thank you very much everybody for
listening don't forget you can buy
Christian Hosoi is both through Amazon
through our web page and then we'll get
alone you'll get a little star for you
going through our web page to buy
Christmas toys book pool all the
information will be on by the book
get a message in a bomb go watch him
speak
this Sunday if you have chance bro Rhys
Ryan riess his son - we're so full